[Music]
so the super bowl is happening
56 yep 50 cent wait who 56.
number 46
50 cent yeah 50 cents no but the the
halftime show does have some epic like
90s rappers
let's go
yeah wow it's all the la hitters yeah
the trailer the teaser trailer you can
see the trailer for it it's really sick
actually it'll make you hype even if you
don't get i can't play it or we'll get
taken down but
the kids even don't know how they are
yeah maybe it's for us maybe it's not
for them well thank god finally i don't
know that the super bowl halftime show
always reflects the youth
first of all snoop dogg is always
relevant when you're yeah snoop dogg is
somehow always relevant yeah yeah second
of all eminem just bought a board ape so
it's like he's kind of relevant again
yeah yeah true and he smoked machine gun
kelly a couple of like but you know that
they don't actually you know he's not
actually sitting there buying that [ __ ]
right his assistant's buying it no no no
it's these companies going hey we'll
give you a board ape
right so you you you get the board ape
from us create more hype and it creates
more hype because now eminem bought a
board eight and then like you know
justin bieber got a board ape it's the
same [ __ ]
oh they don't buy it for what they say
it's it's they they get a board worth
one point whatever million
so like
the company buys it like the board ape
company buys it themselves and gives it
to them
uh yeah whoever that i mean whoever the
is behind it right it's all a scam nfcs
are scammed stay away
they're not don't say that please
definitely invested in nfcs me too me
too me too i have a friend that's making
like nfts right now he's such a good
friend that season give me one i don't
even have to buy it damn who's that i
want to get a free one i have a friend
like that too this room right now he
told me that he told me that 20 times
nick
and it's not me this is crazy i'm gonna
make it totally give me one it's on
camera now see
i heard the same thing me too me too
ryan would do it he's 19 he's worth 19
million dollars
are you guys going to watch the super
bowl yeah dude because it's not it's the
so the bengals have not been to the
super bowl since 1989 that joe board
kid's pretty good joe burrows real
[ __ ] good joey b throws the ball real
hard
real hard real hard um and then they're
up against the rams which you know just
moved back to l.a a couple years ago oh
dell it's pretty hyped yeah they used to
be st louis rams before that they were
the la rams again so
i remember when they're the la rams
because i had a helmet the [ __ ]
spiral blue and yellow yeah they're best
uniforms i just love football dude like
playing football on the street and
[ __ ] everywhere two-hand touch not
full tackle cause we men you know and
then the bully's on the street
bullying on the street dog playing they
always want to be like hey you guys want
to play football because they want to
tackle children yeah
i'm tough you could tackle me yeah
you're just playing the pavement because
that's real tackling dude no we did it
on the grass
baby tackling but i do remember we
always played two-hand touch on the
pavement but someone would always push
the slack the other guy and then we'll
tumble the game would end because they
cry and they're like don't tell your mom
please don't tell your mom and that's
what happens yeah i thought they're
supposed to be men though
yeah but we're like what third grade man
when steve said you know what's gonna
make us really care about the super
bowls if we have a lot of money
so let's talk about it let's talk about
it we can do a bet so how much i think i
think if we put a lot of money and do
this collective bet it's going to make
us enjoy the [ __ ] out of it really so we
all got to bed on the same team right
yeah i think so yeah who do you think
what are we doing odds are we doing are
we doing the gamble style are we just
doing the team we're just doing the team
there's that guy did you see recently
there's a guy it's like the biggest
historic online bet i think he bet like
3.5 million or something like that oh
something mac is his name
um china china
but if he wins oh mattress mac is his
name macintosh oh sorry mattress mac i
think his name is mattress mac and uh if
he wins
all the ladies
is this a sleep number ceo or something
he's gonna he's gonna get 7.5 million
he's the sealy's founder biggest bet
online ever
wait so if he wins he like just barely
doubles his money because he might be
betting on the doubling not the underdog
yeah but if you lose
that's a that's a risky back maybe he
maybe he's that's like going to the
casino with 3.5 million be like uh
roulette uh let's go uh black hmm
sweet might be a baller we're gonna do
the money line that's more under the
money line because usually when you bet
the odds on a team it's it's it's
usually like that like it's it's like
it's not like a full on five times
multiple who are there
right now the rams are the favorites to
win
the bangles are plus 165 on the money
line which means if you bet 100 then you
get 165 back right do they take bets on
just the first coin toss yeah oh they do
they do they have so many fun side bets
can we bet on which stores are going to
get looted during that year if they're
like
because we usually don't have crazy
stuff like there's not
i haven't seen like nut nutty fandom
here like the way that they do it out in
the east coast no that's true if it was
the evils i would say
right next to the sofa what about the
lakers one though didn't they go nuts
over there but that's because he's
saying the fan base is huge out here for
the lakers but like the rams are back
and everyone's kind of wondering if
there's still a lot of fans there
obviously are because the population
valley is so big when the lakers won
they recently they won in the bubble in
orlando so like everybody was already
like [ __ ] home like just [ __ ]
what's it called the cabin fever yeah so
getting out i was i was one of those too
just getting out and just being in the
parking lot area of staples and just
going crazy was the only thing you could
do
so [ __ ] you go out there and people
are lighting fireworks and [ __ ] like
that and then people are like uh in
their apartment balconies they they
pulled out their speakers and people
were djing they were just like street
parties it was honestly fun as [ __ ]
you kind of just forget forget about
coding first that was fireworks savings
and [ __ ]
you know you don't got a firewall i
don't have a fireworks experience well
do you have firework savings yeah yeah
especially people in my old neighborhood
in l.a if i have fireworks i use it all
for fourth of july and then i'll have
savings well remember the whole [ __ ]
conspiracy where like fireworks were
just going off every day in l.a for a
moment
yeah but and then people were like
they're just hiding gunshots because
they're going out there and killing the
minorities remember that yeah yeah yeah
i was wild and then the dodgers won too
yeah at the same time
crazy here what are we betting if we're
gonna do this together yeah we have to
decide on how much we're betting okay
who are we betting on i believe that the
rams are gonna win that's why the same
regardless i would still have to bet on
the rams i would be happier if the
bengals one because of the story and
they haven't won and the odds ever
wouldn't you get paid more if you like
yeah for sure
where are we betting are we going to go
to vegas and do this and just put it on
a bet i mean we we live there so it's
very easy i could call a bookie
look also when was the last time a home
team actually where the super bowl was
playing that only happened last year
right so this is the second time ever
yeah the fact that [ __ ] l.a rams in
la are at the super bowl like gotta bet
on that late well plus air donald's so
[ __ ] good and i don't know if you
guys watched the playoff games but joe
bro got sacked so many times
that i think that they're not going to
have a chance against aaron donald so
that's the key to victory yeah is going
to be there so what happens if like if
you put like a thousand dollars on the
rams how much are you going to win
um like 1 600.
i'm with it oh wait oh if you off the
rams i don't know i haven't checked that
you know i said that was on on bengals
once it's five
are we pulling are we all pulling money
together i think we should should we all
put in like what 200 bucks a person i'll
bet mo you i'll then know somebody right
now and you guys go back to vegas put
that bet in okay all right wait do we
have time how do we do it oh yeah yeah
yeah we're playing time
all the game just happened no the gate
no the pro bowls this weekend next
weekend but do they still accept bets
like
do they do the uh
change the odds change at the closer
yeah they do they do because depending
on say people think i thought they had
their last game they have one more game
yeah the super bowl is the game oh yeah
that's the last game yeah yeah yeah okay
what's the pro bowl then that's not a
that's like the all-star game oh cool
yeah but nobody really cares when's the
last time you watched a football game
like honestly like sat down and because
i haven't watched you know sit down and
watch the full game like probably since
the last super bowl you wanna know what
never
what about the one that okay
what about the one in thanksgiving
uh yeah did you watch that that's the
one that i usually watch because i it's
because we our family plays it and then
like so like when we hang out during
thanksgiving that's when i usually watch
football i see yeah it's usually the
lion's plan
this year was the colts i actually
played which is cool and the lions
played too
hey the game before the nfc
championships though the bills and the
sheep oh my god one of the best games
i've ever watched my whole life that was
so crazy i don't know like because i'm
not into football but then like i'm into
gambling i think i'm gonna really get
into sports soon
because i'm gonna sports bet yeah me too
because all my like man so what you're
saying is you're gonna get into gambling
what sport what sport are you going to
do you could gamble all i know but what
specifically are you do you want the
ones that have bedding on them okay
all of them okay
i want to build my nephew sports bet
with my with you know with my cousin and
stuff so i want to i want to get into it
with them canadian gymnastics i love
watching games in vegas out in in public
like at the bars like at the casino
the energy's amazing the screens are
[ __ ] unbelievable there's always a
huge screen bigger than your whole life
how come you don't go to the sports bed
area they got those i do oh that's where
you go yeah they have those couches you
can [ __ ] see those massive [ __ ]
games and [ __ ] you see everything just
ceiling mountain it's huge they are they
are they do know what that means
especially that one casino man best [ __ ]
right well um the best [ __ ] is when
you're there
everybody next to you thinks that you
bet too even though i've never been on a
sports game in my life
really never never i don't really i
don't gamble but i'm i'm i'm because of
the degeneracy of vegas and how these
guys are i kind of just want to
experience it with them and play around
all that yeah so because they'll sit
there and they're like they're like uh
like yes and like oh you bet the under
huh and i'm like oh no i just i i i
didn't bet on this at all i'm looking
are you mad at you yeah yeah it's just
like you're they're trying to get you
bet the other people involved like what
the [ __ ] going on dude
they're trying to recruit everybody
there's bet and they all assume that you
better today's video is brought to you
by bombas
mission is simple make the most
comfortable clothes ever and match every
item sold with an item donated so when
you buy bombas you're also giving to
someone in need boomba designed their
socks shirts and underwear to be the
clothes you can't wait to put on every
day everything they make is soft tagless
seamless and has a luxuriously cozy feel
they're made from super soft materials
like merino wool
prima cotton and even cashmere which
makes them the perfect cozy winter
layers there's also a pair of bumble
socks for everything that you do they
come in tons of options like comfy
performance socks for everything that
you do and all the activities that keep
you moving boom boss t-shirts are made
with thoughtful design features like
invisible seams soft fabrics and the
perfect weight so they hang just right
bomba's underwear has a barely there
feel with second skin support they might
almost make you feel like you're not
even wearing anything and did you know
that socks underwear and t-shirts are
the three most requested items in
homeless shelters and that's why bombas
donates one for every item you buy so go
to bombus.com off the record to get
twenty dollars off every purchase that's
b-o-m-b-a-s-com
off the record to get 20 percent off
your purchase because every item you buy
gets donated and it's a good cause and
it's super comfy go check it out check
it out i have like this the the right
and proper like uh reactions like you
got to have like an open-ended positive
negative like something happens you're
like wow
yeah yeah yeah
dude last night this guy
this guy was so wasted at this at this
bar i was i was watching the laker game
because you were there
and i was i was it's a great game by the
way this guy got so wasted i was wearing
my colts um sweatshirt and he comes up
to me he's like
hey you used to play for the colts huh
look my name's andrew luck what's up
[ __ ] wait is that does that happen to
every white guy wearing a jersey you pay
for the colts huh and i'm like no no i
never played for goals he's like no dude
he's like i was the de i was a deeds
like i know you played for the colts i
was like i swear to god i never played
the goals like my parents wouldn't even
play high school football because i
thought i'd get killed
what's a d e
but don't you know all the stats of the
colts i'm pretty big fan you should have
just like [ __ ] mocked him and played
it on well that i don't need him to
think i'm a colts guy he might be so
cool though yeah i would leave him alone
exactly you asking what his name was
no i was too scared he was [ __ ]
wasted and i was afraid that if i kept
denying him for too long he was going to
try to beat me up or something did he
look like he could have been in
defensive end uh i think he no because
he was thin he was tall but thin but he
was like
ten six foot
six five ten six foot huh
yeah so yeah he really definitely
thought that and then his buddy was like
hey bro he's like i'm about to knock
that fool out right there i gotta go
[Laughter]
is it because of my story no because um
remember we all played uh we all played
circus circus we all played craps
remember that yeah
you guys came out the game hot we got
bro
you guys were like
but remember i'm so nervous so i lost i
lost like 600 bucks in less than 30
minutes right so i was talking to steve
and i was like 10 minutes i was maybe 10
minutes or less i bought him three times
i got wiped out each time dude yeah
and then i was like i was like i was
like steve i was like did you feel
anything and you're like nah and i'm
like me neither i think i should quit
gambling because um that used to excite
me yeah
to me that was like flipping a quarter
in a fountain
but i'm no millionaire right so it's
like it's like being a [ __ ]
gazillionaire and then being like a
hundred thousand nothing right because
of crypto like playing 200 bucks doesn't
feel like anything anymore i know but i
need that 600 dude yeah i get it it's
like i shouldn't be playing with that
that's why you need a sports bet because
there's excitement and inherent
excitement when you watch something that
you you're betting on i think the next
number is for me is like i have to play
six figures or it's not going to be
exciting oh my god it's that high so joe
opens this conversation by saying he
doesn't want to gamble and he's like i
have to do six figures where i can't
feel anything can i love this man
speakers on the rams is what is that
what you're saying maybe i throw my 200
bucks in with that yeah yeah yeah
hundred thousand
same odds bro even split at the end no
matter what yeah
i want you to feel good you know it's
not about us yeah yeah we put it in the
pot so what does it mean because i don't
know [ __ ] about about like i said sports
gambling the money line total for the
rams is negative 190. so if i put in 100
bucks can i see that i don't know
like actual sports betting like with uh
like scoring sports all right kind of
confusing i get the plus right the 160
put in 100 bucks you win 160. the the
negative 190 i don't get that that means
if they win we lose everything
we have to pay them
another 90 bucks holy [ __ ] i thought i'd
bet on that dude joe's not excited at
all he doesn't give up he's a hundred
dollars
he's like you need to kick me in the
ball so i get my [ __ ] i've spent so
much more on it it'll [ __ ] put hair
on your ass
i got a lot of hair on my ass i gotta
shave it oh [ __ ] sorry no this let's
really do this we're doing 200 bucks
so what do we get back if we win
i think we lose we're moving
i think i think we get a thousand we
were betty
we're betting on the rams to win and we
lose money
because we know you can make money
otherwise we're [ __ ] there's a
negative dude
dude that'd be pretty [ __ ] is that
how it works have you guys sports bet
before yeah no i never did okay you have
yeah have you ever been on fights though
have you ever bet on someone because
usually
like i've never sports bet before so i
would think i would always bet on the
person i want to win but then you but
it's now a business so you might want to
bet on the other person have you ever
been on the other person oh dude 100
there's so many times where i've bet on
people that i thought
that i really liked but i bet on the
other person so but doesn't that make
you feel bad because you're not rooting
for your person your favorite person to
lose but it's but it's like picks it's
analysis that's like it's because i pick
for fights sometimes so when i do for
fights
i look at it from like okay what are the
chances this person's going what's their
way to win yada yada and then you kind
of break it down you take your own
favoritism aside i think you have you
have to be objective with it right yeah
he's good at that winning the fight and
winning money are two different things
exactly but then also too it's like are
you playing just for fun are you are you
planning to win because i used to do
like 12 fight parlays and i put like 10
bucks down because when i was like 21
and i would just do that every now and
then and i would hit like 11 out of 12
sometimes that would hit like one time i
won like a seven fight uh parley
and i won like like 500 bucks from like
20 dollars wow but it's but you have to
figure out like when you're doing
parlays you have to figure out if i keep
picking favorites i have to pick way
more favorites to get some value but
then i have to throw an underdog every
now and then that i think is undervalued
so then i could make that worth my like
the bengals right exactly about it so
that mgm's offering negative 200 on the
rams to win the super bowl so you win
100 for every 200 that you wager oh
that's not a good roi man so it's 50
they're heavily favoring the rams yeah
so we put in 1200 right now we're all
gonna [ __ ] get one hundred dollars
each
the question is pretty good the question
is do you guys
wanna win a little bit guaranteed or a
lot of bit if i'm listening let's put in
just go let's go [ __ ] bangles
let's go [ __ ] bangles because if we
win we being win big if we lose
we [ __ ] lose just 200 bucks
i probably don't want to lose 200 bucks
right now because i'm homeless but still
every time joey b gets sacked i'm gonna
be like god damn it
hey hey but it feels good struggling
together
i don't know if i want to be conflicted
during the game though because it's not
like we're betting six figures yeah he's
always conflicted though he's always
betting on the other guy yeah but he's
he's conflicted as a human joe are you
going to be in vegas
oh what date is it next sunday
oh you are
boys
let's [ __ ] go okay if the bengals win
what's their path to victory like how do
you see them winning they have to well
they have to protect the quarterback
that's it if they can get the o-line up
and running and actually protect joe
burrow then they have a shot because him
and jamar chase have an unbelievable
connection like not since peyton manning
and marvin harrison have i seen two wide
receivers or like a wide receiver
quarterback duo like hook up the way
that they do and just know each other
all the time
yeah what are the what are the odds
though like if payout odds if we if we
go native 190 bengals or i'm sorry
plus 190. negative 190 for the rams and
then for the bengals it's it's uh plus
160. so oh so the odds aren't even that
good for the bengals to win well for
every 100 that we put in we get 160 so
we get 60 bucks for our bet
oh that's how it works 160 160. yeah we
get 160 yeah but like you know
oh yeah yeah
so it's either a 50 dollar win
uh 60. are we even smart enough to
gamble i don't think we are so i think
we're showing that we should spreaders
are just watching just like you guys are
[ __ ] morons well we've never done it
i don't know yeah i don't know someone
will teach me side bets are more funny
side bits are fun okay do you wanna do
funny [ __ ] why don't we put like four
grand on like the first play has to be a
safety yeah
and then we all we can win like two
million dollars but people do win crazy
amounts of money crazy the bets on those
things are crazy wait isn't the math on
that if we bet a hundred dollars
for the bengals then they're gonna give
us 165 on top of the 100 back yes
whereas if we bet 100
on the ramps then we'll get 50 on top of
our 100 150 yeah versus 260. yeah it's
on top of it back
yeah you should get it back
yeah
like if you bet on rams but a very
specific detail about yeah like a like a
over under something like that that's
called the spread so if you bet it like
if you bet it's pretty tough within this
point spread then yeah can you bet stuff
like dr jay's gonna pick his nose during
the halftime show or something yeah you
could start that bet and then see if
people see what the odds are i want to
know the vegas odds on that
let's let's be honest here most of us is
our first song let's just make it easy
let's not over complicate stuff let's
just bet on our favorite team go for the
rams really just intro that you know
what i mean and then be done with this
i'm going bangles now you convinced me
actually
oh my god
why
one la two they're favored when i make
money i'd rather make fifty bucks than
lose on the idea hey guess who's
favorite cheese versus bengals bro and
guess who won yep it's not your favorite
guarantee that's true yeah you're
absolutely right you were 18 you eight
to one
just saying i want to watch the game and
as i'm voting for my my city to win also
feeling like i won if the city won yeah
then you're not a gambler
you want to feel the spirit or this
okay
if the wind goes that way he goes that
way joe is like solidarity oh but money
boys
i workshop and brainstorm is that okay
so who wants the bank who wants the
better the bengals right what okay which
one can get me more profit bengals yeah
i don't know anything i don't know i'm
not connected to anybody so [ __ ] it
i'll send you to whatever money you guys
are [ __ ] ramsers yeah dude i'm a huge
jared goff fan because i'm from la and i
remember them so you're going to rams
now
i'm trying to finish my statement here
is that i like them right but i also
like gambling oh i want to win big oh
that's what i'm saying do you want to
win little guaranteed or do you want to
win [ __ ] [ __ ] but you also got to
imagine the feeling though you imagine
the feeling right of like the what is it
they go by quarters huh yeah oh my god
bart yeah i don't know so they go by
court on the last quarter what do they
go about i don't know they go by
quarters yeah the last quarter do you
want to be cheering against l.a it's the
feeling when you're watching it right
you want to be training against i don't
even watch football so i have no
feelings attached
that defeats the whole purpose of sports
betting i do like aaron donald because
you wanna play and bet and watch dude
you're gonna you're gonna get such an
adrenaline rush when you win two hundred
dollars when the bengals there's gonna
be a 40 minute video of us arguing what
you don't on the guy who doesn't even
watch football we have to pick one
before the video i think i think it's
funnier if because joe just wants to bet
and not even watch the game i think it's
funny if one person goes bengals that's
a way [ __ ] i'll do it yeah let's go
juggle bagels and then he goes bangles
and then we revisit this next next otr
after the super i like it and that's the
best [ __ ] i think joe just shits on all
of our faces yeah because there's a big
potential for him to [ __ ]
destroy us which is fine he's going to
destroy us by winning a whole 160 bucks
and i don't even watch sports and he
won't even know if he won or not he's
not watching we could just tell him who
we think won and then he'll he'll just
be like okay take his winnings and split
it yeah let's do that
okay
i have google full go round
if that's the case we don't even have to
place the bet we could just bet among us
literally we could tell joe about games
that aren't even happening
you